.
Noch heute fassen mir
ab und zu Menschen in die Haare,
weil sie wissen möchten,
wie sich solche Locken anfühlen.
Guten Tag, meine Damen und Herren,
ich begrüsse Sie
zur Mittagsausgabe der "Tagesschau".
Heute ist es
nicht mehr die Schokolade,
das getraut sich niemand mehr.
Aber es ist Latte macchiato
oder Café mélange.
Das sagen Leute zu dir?
- Ja.
Und was sagst du dann?
- Nichts.
* Applaus *
Ich wollte den Rassismus
eigentlich gar nicht sehen.
Ich wurde so erzogen ...
... dass ich ihn
teilweise gar nicht sah.
* Rhythmische Musik *
Angélique Beldner -
die erste schwarze News-Moderatorin
des Schweizer Fernsehens.
Ihre Hautfarbe
wollte sie nie zum Thema machen.
Doch dieser Sommer
hat ihr Leben verändert.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
(Sprechchöre) Black lives matter!
Black lives matter!
6. Juni 2020: Tausende von Menschen
gehen in der Schweiz auf die Strasse
und protestieren
gegen Rassismus im eigenen Land.
Angélique Beldner
kommt in ein Dilemma.
Weil ich mir über all die Jahre
eine Strategie zurechtgelegt habe,
die mir möglichst nicht wehtut.
Es zeigt sich daran,
dass ich praktisch nie
über Rassismus gesprochen habe
und auch nicht
darüber sprechen wollte.
Es zeigt sich daran, dass ich
Rassismus entschuldigt habe,
dass ich z.B. gesagt habe,
das sei alles nicht böse gemeint.
Ich war viel zu lange viel zu nett.
Und das hat sich
diesen Sommer geändert.
Ich finde:
Das muss jetzt aufhören.
Es ist Mitte August.
Angélique Beldner
ist auf dem Weg ins Berner Oberland.
(Durchsage) Frutigen.
In Frutigen hat sie die ersten Jahre
ihrer Kindheit verbracht.
Die Mutter war zu der Zeit
Lehrerin im Dorf.
Sie unterstützt Angélique Beldner bei
der Aufarbeitung ihrer Geschichte,
aber nicht vor der Kamera.
Jetzt geht sie zur Grosstante,
bei der sie damals zusammen
mit ihrer Mutter gewohnt hat.
* Türsummer *
Ja, hallo.
Begrüssen wir uns so?
* Kussgeräusche, Lachen *
Es ist halt etwas anders als sonst.
Grosstante Lydia Schlup
und deren Tochter Béatrice gehörten
zu den engsten Bezugspersonen
in Angéliques Beldners Kindheit.
Über Rassismus oder ihre Hautfarbe
sprach sie mit ihnen noch nie.
Als ich zur Welt kam
und ihr mich das erste Mal saht,
wie war das?
Dich hat man aufgenommen,
wie du warst. Fertig.
Man machte sich keine Gedanken,
du könntest evtl. anders aussehen
oder würdest nicht hierhergehören.
Du warst von Anfang an
in die Familie integriert.
Wir nahmen das
als selbstverständlich.
Du hast auch von Anfang an
unsere Sprache gesprochen.
Das hat viel ausgemacht.
Du hast dich verhalten
wie unsere Kinder und andere.
Das macht viel aus.
Du lagst friedlich und zufrieden
in diesem weissen Bettchen.
Du warst nicht mal so mokkafarben,
sage ich jetzt mal.
Aber plötzlich
wurde die Haut dunkler,
und die Haare
begannen sich zu krausen.
Seid ihr erschrocken?
Nein, wir kannten ja deinen Vater,
haben ihn gesehen.
Deshalb war es keine Überraschung.
Dachtest du nicht,
es wäre einfacher gewesen,
wenn dieses Mädchen
so geblieben wäre?
Vielleicht wäre es
für dich einfacher gewesen.
Aber mir hat es nichts ausgemacht.
Wohlbehütet sei sie aufgewachsen,
sagt Angélique Beldner.
Zur alleinerziehenden Mutter
mit dem schwarzen, unehelichen Kind
habe kaum jemand Fragen gestellt.
Die Familie war angesehen im Dorf.
Angélique Beldners Vater
war weit weg.
Der Informatiker aus Paris
und ihre Mutter
waren drei Jahre ein Paar.
Vor der Geburt
der gemeinsamen Tochter
trennte sich die Mutter von ihm.
Wie wäre es gewesen
oder was hätte sich geändert,
wenn mein Vater, der in Paris war
und in Paris geblieben ist,
in die Schweiz gekommen wäre?
Wenn er da gewesen gewesen wäre,
dann wäre es ähnlich gewesen,
wie man es jetzt erlebt,
wenn Leute aus dem Ausland kommen.
Sei es aus Paris oder Eritrea.
Zuerst einmal stellt sich die Frage,
ob der Mann arbeitet.
Das ist hier im Dorf
schon sehr wichtig.
Gut, bei ihm wäre es
wohl eher umgekehrt gewesen:
Deine Mutter
hätte weiterhin gearbeitet
und er wäre Hausmann geworden.
Ihn hätten wir
nicht auch noch aufgenommen.
Eine ganze Familie
hätten wir nicht aufgenommen.
Inmitten einer weissen Umgebung
wuchs Angélique Beldner auf.
Seit ihrer Kindheit stecke dieses
Gefühl vom Sich-anpassen-Wollen
tief in ihr drin.
Dazugehören -
zu einer weissen Mehrheit.
Wie habt ihr es so mit Begriffen?
Wie steht ihr
zur Mohrenkopf-Debatte?
Das passt dir vielleicht nicht,
aber Mohrenköpfe sind für mich
immer noch Mohrenköpfe.
Und sie werden das
vorläufig auch bleiben.
Aber vielleicht
ändere ich ja mal meine Meinung.
Weisst du, mir sagte man Mohrenkopf
als Schimpfwort,
mir hat man das hinterhergerufen.
Ich reagiere deshalb vielleicht ein
bisschen empfindlich, wenn man sagt:
"Ich nannte das schon immer so
und werde dies auch weiterhin tun."
Verstehst du das,
oder müsste ich mich ändern?
Ich verstehe deine Sichtweise,
bleibe aber bei meiner Meinung.
Da wäre eine Anpassung
unsererseits gefragt.
Das ist meine klare Meinung.
Man sollte mit der Sprache
niemanden absichtlich verletzen.
Das finde ich nicht gut.
Man muss es erst mal einsehen
und ändern wollen.
Man muss es erkennen.
Solange ich das Gefühl habe,
es sei lustig ...
Es ist nicht so wichtig, warum
gibt man dem diese Wichtigkeit?
Aber ich fand es
schon als Kind nicht lustig,
und zwar ganz und gar nicht.
- Echt? - Nein, gar nicht.
Und dann musste ich
den schwarzen Mann spielen,
das fand ich auch nicht lustig.
Ja, das kann ich
schon eher verstehen.
Und trotzdem: Es ist ein Spiel.
Ob man das jetzt alles
auf sich beziehen will ...
Ich habe Zeit meines Lebens
bessere Erfahrungen gemacht,
wenn ich solche Dinge
nicht angesprochen habe.
Es ist für mich viel einfacher,
den Mohrenkopf zu akzeptieren
und dich zu akzeptieren,
wie du bist,
dass du das Mohrenkopf nennst,
und mir zu sagen:
"Es hat mit mir nichts zu tun,
ich nehme es nicht persönlich",
als eine solche Diskussion
zu führen,
bei der ich erkenne,
dass du einen Standpunkt hast,
von dem du nicht abweichst.
Es ist für mich
die schwierigere Einsicht,
dass meine Mama Lily,
die mich grossgezogen hat,
dieses Ding
immer noch Mohrenkopf nennt.
Du bleibst beharrlich
bei deinem Standpunkt.
Denk du nur,
ich sei uneinsichtig.
Ich stehe dazu.
Ich will mein Mäntelchen
nicht nach dem Wind hängen,
nur weil es
jemand anderem nicht passt,
und dann meine Meinung ändern.
Ist es heute noch okay,
Mohrenkopf zu sagen?
Oder gehört der Begriff dorthin,
wo er herkam, nämlich ins 19. Jh.?
Eine Tradition verletzt
und würdigt herab.
Das erstmals zu benennen,
sei nicht einfach,
sagt Angélique Beldner.
Ein Problem ist natürlich,
dass ich dann als eine Person gelte,
die ich nicht bin.
Z.B. als empfindlich.
Als jemand,
der sich dauernd auflehnt,
eine Schwierige, eine Komplizierte.
Das sind alles Eigenschaften,
die ich eher als negativ empfinde.
So möchte ich nicht sein,
und ich behaupte auch,
dass ich nicht so bin.
Und wenn ich jetzt aufstehe
und sage,
dass ich dies und jenes
nicht mehr will,
dann muss ich in Kauf nehmen,
dass mir diese Eigenschaften
nachgesagt werden.
In ihrem Leben nahm sie bisher den
für sie einfacheren Weg: schweigen.
Ich finde es schön,
dass man im Fernsehen
auch Menschen wie dich zeigt.
Als ich dich das erste Mal in der
18-Uhr-"Tagesschau" gesehen habe,
waren deine Haare
derart nach hinten frisiert,
dass ich dich
fast nicht erkannt habe.
Ich fragte mich:
"Was machen die nur mit dir?"
Ich bin es gewohnt,
dass du Locken hast,
aber die Haare
waren nach hinten frisiert.
Ich hatte das Gefühl, sie wollen
dich nicht so, wie du bist.
Wolltest du dir das Haar
nach hinten frisieren lassen?
Das ist eben genau der Punkt.
Ich hatte das Gefühl,
es stehe mir gar nicht zu,
mir genau zu überlegen,
was ich möchte.
Ich lasse mir sagen,
was möglich ist.
Und wenn sie mir sagen, es sei nicht
möglich, weil es nicht gut aussieht,
wegen des Lichts usw.,
dann glaube ich das.
Und da sind wir wieder
bei der Geschichte von früher.
Möglichst anpassen, möglichst ...
Es soll stimmen.
Und bei dieser Geschichte
findest du,
ich hätte aufstehen
und sagen sollen:
"Hey, stopp, Moment!"
"Ich möchte das gerne anders."
- Genau.
Man kann es ja anständig sagen.
Sie sollen es ausprobieren
und die Reaktionen abwarten.
Aber so wurde ich nicht erzogen.
Darum brauchst du jetzt
diesen Prozess, um zu wissen,
was du selber willst,
und wo du stehst.
Genau. Ja.
Das ist die erste "Tagesschau"
an diesem heissen Mittwoch.
Ich begrüsse Sie zur Sendung
mit diesen Themen.
SRF-Chefstylistin Tatjana Kotoric
ordnet den Auftritt ein.
Wie bei allen SRF-Moderatoren
und -Moderatorinnen
wählten wir auch für Angélique
bei ihrem Moderationsstart 2015
ein Styling, das zu den News passt:
elegant und ausdrucksstark.
Unsere Stylingrichtlinien 2015
waren so,
dass die Kleider und die Haare
elegant wirken,
aber durch Volumen oder Dominanz
nicht zu sehr
vom Inhalt ablenken sollten.
Das war uns
bei allen Moderatoren wichtig.
Das waren stets
unsere Beurteilungskriterien.
Inzwischen
ist die Businessmode viel lockerer.
Frauen tragen oft Seidenblusen
mit Jupes oder Kleidern,
und auch die Haare
dürfen lockerer getragen werden.
Fünf Jahre ist es her.
Heute trägt Angélique Beldner
ihr Haar am Bildschirm auch offen.
Haar und Hautfarbe
sind die offensichtlichen Merkmale,
die darauf schliessen lassen,
dass sie einen
anderen kulturellen Hintergrund hat.
Doch damit
liegt man bei ihr grundfalsch.
Schon als Kind
konnte ich die Frage nach
meiner Herkunft nicht ausstehen.
Wenn jemand fragte, woher ich komme,
antwortete ich stets: "Aus Bern."
Und wenn dann jemand nachfragte,
woher ich wirklich komme,
antwortete ich:
"Ich komme wirklich aus Bern."
Und wenn dann jemand
nach meinen Wurzeln fragte,
antwortete ich nochmals:
"Die sind in Bern."
Was wirklich wehtut:
Wenn man solche Fragen
immer und immer wieder hört,
und zwar sehr früh
in einem Gespräch,
dann empfinde ich das so,
als würde man mir sagen:
"Du bist nicht Teil dessen,
was wir hier haben."
Hoi, Tristan.
Mit SRF-Chefredaktor Tristan Brenn
will sie erstmals über eine Erfahrung
im Fernsehen reden,
die mit ihrer Hautfarbe zu tun hat.
Als ich mich vor 15 Jahren erstmals
für die "Tagesschau" bewarb,
sagte man mir,
die Schweiz sei noch nicht so weit,
noch nicht bereit für eine
dunkelhäutige News-Moderatorin.
Ich kann das fast nicht glauben.
Das ist nicht ewig her,
das war vor 15 Jahren.
Wenn man hier im Haus
das Gefühl gehabt hätte,
gewisse Leute
könnten Anstoss nehmen
an einer Moderatorin
mit einer anderen Hautfarbe,
hätte man den Schritt erst recht
wagen und dich anstellen müssen.
Wurde dir das so als Begründung
mitgeteilt? Oder wie war das damals?
Das hat man mir nicht direkt gesagt.
Direkt sagte man mir,
es gäbe halt noch andere Gründe,
aber hintenherum
habe ich davon erfahren.
Dann hast du nachgefragt,
was die anderen Gründe seien,
und dann stellte sich heraus ...
- Genau.
Ich bin sehr überrascht
über eine solche Aussage,
über eine solche Wertung.
Ich kann es mir nicht erklären.
Ich sage dir,
was ich damals gedacht habe:
Ich fand es gar nicht so schlimm.
Fandest du es nicht so schlimm,
weil du dir
solche Dinge gewohnt warst?
Ich war es gewohnt
und verstand es auch.
Wenn man nicht weiss, wie das Land
auf jemanden wie mich reagiert,
ist es vielleicht besser,
wenn man es sein lässt.
Das ist ...
Du hast so gedacht, ja.
Fernsehzuschauer und -zuschauerinnen,
die sie als Mensch abwerten,
weil sie eine andere Hautfarbe hat,
die gibt es.
Einige Zuschauer
sind eindeutig rassistisch.
Die schreiben mir z.B.,
es reiche mit der Vernegerung.
Und dann gibt negative Kommentare,
von denen ich nicht
eindeutig sagen kann,
ob sie etwas
mit Rassismus zu tun haben.
Eine Frau schrieb mir z.B.,
ich soll das WC putzen gehen.
Dafür sei ich gut genug,
sonst für gar nichts.
Die Kultur der Schweiz sei bedroht,
wenn mehr schwarze Menschen
das öffentliche Bild prägen -
so eine Umfrage des Bundesamtes
für Statistik aus dem Jahr 2017.
Guten Tag zusammen.
Wir sind zurück in Frutigen,
am Stammtisch
des Restaurants Simplon.
Angélique Beldner
stellt sich der Rassismusdiskussion.
Mich dünkt einfach das Wort Neger
nicht unbedingt falsch bzw. schlimm.
Wäre ich dann ein Neger für Sie?
Ich weiss nicht,
was schlimm daran ist,
wenn ich ihn Neger nenne.
Nicht irgendjemand, sondern ich:
Bin ich ein Neger?
Ich glaube nicht.
- Nein, nicht.
Und warum nicht?
Ein Neger ist für mich
etwas ganz anderes.
Was denn?
- Es ist auch nichts Schlimmes.
Was ist denn anders?
Dann bist du halt eine Negerin.
Das ist auch nichts Schlimmes.
Wir nennen dich Neger,
weil du schwarz bist.
Ja.
Wir nennen dich aber nicht so,
weil das für uns
etwas Negatives ist.
Das ist der Ursprung.
Was war der schwarze Mann
ursprünglich?
Das war der Sklave,
das war der Nigger.
Ich würde sagen,
daher kommt dieses Wort.
Genau, und was heisst das für Sie?
Dass Sie dieses Wort
nicht verwenden?
Nein, sicher nicht.
Das war ein Sklave, nicht wahr?
Ich sagte nie Neger,
weil es ein böses Wort ist.
Klar sagte man: "Du huere Neger."
"Ich bin doch nicht dein Neger."
Und schon
widersprichst du dir.
Schon widersprichst du dir.
- Ja, das sagte man.
Eben, aus welchem Grund
hast du es gesagt?
Darfst du nicht mehr machen -
also hey, hallo?
Aus welchem Grund
hast du es gesagt?
Weil er nicht gut gearbeitet hat.
Aber er hat ...
- Ja.
Weil er ein fauler Kerl war?
- Ja, genau. - Eine mistfaule Ratte.
Aber er hätte das dir ja
vielleicht auch sagen können.
Das nicht gerade, aber ...
- Du bist manchmal auch so.
Ja.
Eine Definition von Rassismus ist,
Menschen
auf ihre Herkunft reduzieren,
ihnen kollektive Merkmale zuschreiben
und sie deswegen herabsetzen.
Rassendiskriminierung kenne ich
hier im Berner Oberland nicht.
Das ist ja umso besser.
Wir haben so viele Touristen.
Wir haben auch Schlitzaugen,
wir haben Schwarze ...
Du bist eine schöne Brasilianerin,
eben angebräunt.
Eine willkommene ...
Bei deiner Rasse glaube ich nicht,
dass jemand fragen würde:
"Woher kommst du?"
Doch, das werde ich häufig gefragt.
- Echt?
Z.B. komme ich
auch nicht aus Brasilien.
Ja, aber vielleicht
wollen sie auch fragen ...
Männlich, ja:
"Ich hätte mit dir gerne Kinder."
Aha, du hast das Gefühl,
das habe etwas damit zu tun.
Ja, eben, wir hätten schöne Kinder.
Aha.
Bleib, wie du bist.
- Alles Gute, danke.
Du würdest dich nur verwässern.
Das ist schlimm.
Er kommt mir auch viel zu nahe,
nur schon körperlich.
Ich hatte schon lange
keine Nackenschmerzen mehr,
aber jetzt habe ich welche.
Schon als Kind hatte ich das Gefühl,
es fehle die Distanz.
Man spürt die Distanz nicht zu mir.
Oder es sei nicht nötig,
man dürfe mich doch berühren.
Es sei ja interessant, gut gemeint:
"Bist ja ein Herziges."
Wie gehen wir als Gesellschaft
mit Rassismus um?
Darüber müssen wir reden.
Noch den Gedanken fertigmachen,
dann Sie.
Denn auch wenn man
nur Persons of Color einlädt,
gibt es verschiedene Meinungen.
Frau Binkert denkt ganz bestimmt
nicht so wie ich, und du auch nicht.
Und das wäre schön gewesen.
Bei einem Titel
wie "Jetzt sprechen die Schwarzen"
sollte man auch Schwarze einladen,
es ist 50:50.
Diese Sendung
wurde heftig kritisiert.
Von Debakel und Fiasko war die Rede,
weit weg von einer
konstruktiven Rassismusdiskussion.
Der Auftritt von Angela Addo
war für Angélique Beldner wegweisend.
Sie spricht mir aus dem Herzen.
Ich verstehe alles, was sie sagt.
Ich weiss, was sie meint, aber es
kommt bei den anderen nicht an.
Ich wüsste nicht,
was sie anders hätte machen müssen,
damit es ankommt.
Und ich dachte:
"Deshalb sage ich nichts."
Genau darum sage ich nichts,
und sie lief jetzt quasi
ins offene Messer.
Aber gleichzeitig dachte ich:
"Sie läuft auch für mich
ins offene Messer."
Denn es geht nicht nur um sie.
Es geht um uns.
Um uns Schwarze.
Zum ersten Mal
sagte ich selber zu mir:
"Und ich gehöre da dazu.
Ich bin schwarz."
Angélique Beldner trifft die Black-
Lives-Matter-Aktivistin Angela Addo
bei einem Konzert in Zürich.
(Jazzgesang)
# Stormy weather.
# Love me or leave me, let go.
# Say do, say don't ...
# Stormy weather.
Sie will mit Angela Addo
über die Sendung sprechen
und welche Folgen
diese für sie hatte.
Es war für mich sehr brutal,
dort zu sitzen.
Ich kann mich noch sehr gut
an die erste Frage erinnern,
die an Herrn Foley ging:
Gibt es Rassismus in der Schweiz?
Mir fiel die Kinnlade runter.
Dass man so was
überhaupt noch fragt?
Da dachte ich wirklich ...
Ich weiss noch,
wie ich meine Hände zusammenfaltete
und dachte:
"Soll ich jetzt aufstehen,
soll ich einfach aufstehen?"
Aber ich habe es durchgezogen,
worüber ich echt froh bin,
denn Hunderte von Leuten,
die ich gar nicht kenne,
standen nach der Sendung hinter mir.
Das war krass.
Ich meine, ich kriege
auch viele Hassnachrichten.
Aber das bestätigt genau, dass das,
was ich mache, wichtig ist.
Und die erste "Arena"-Sendung
hat ja genau das widergespiegelt,
was uns im Alltag
als schwarze Menschen widerfährt:
Man verleugnet und vertuscht es.
Das Wort Gaslighting
ist ein so wichtiges Wort,
weil man im Alltag
immer wieder erlebt,
dass die Gefühle, die man wahrnimmt,
nicht ernst genommen werden,
und dass gesagt wird:
"Das gibt es nicht."
Rassismuserfahrungen absprechen -
die beiden Frauen
haben es zur Genüge erlebt.
(Durchsage) Paris, Gare de Lyon,
unser Zielbahnhof.
Es ist September.
Angélique Beldner
auf dem Weg zu ihrem Vater.
Mit 20 Jahren hat sie ihren leib-
lichen Vater zum ersten Mal gesehen.
Man hat mir gesagt,
er sei vielleicht in Paris.
Man sagte mir, woher er kommt.
Und meine Mutter hat mir mal
ein paar wenige Sachen geschenkt,
die sie von ihm noch hatte.
Aber ansonsten hat mein Vater
und die Geschichte,
die mit ihm und seiner Herkunft
verbunden ist ...
Davon habe ich nie
etwas mitgekriegt.
* Rhythmische Musik *
In Paris hat sie drei Geschwister.
Ihr Vater kommt ursprünglich
aus der ehemaligen
französischen Kolonie Benin.
Der Kontakt ist lose.
Sie habe die schwarze Familie
auf Distanz gehalten, sagt sie.
Bonjour.
- Bonjour, Albert.
Sei willkommen bei dir zu Hause.
Geht es gut?
- Ja.
Und den Kindern?
- Sehr gut.
Ich freue mich, dich zu sehen.
- Ja, ich mich auch.
Es ist lange, lange her.
Vor 24 Jahren haben wir uns
zum ersten Mal gesehen.
Ich war damals 20.
Du warst 20,
damals am Gare de Lyon.
Gare de Lyon, du erinnerst dich?
Ja.
Wie war das für dich damals?
Als ich dich sah,
war ich glücklich, überglücklich.
Es war ein Wunder.
Du bist meine Tochter,
meine erste Tochter.
Ich habe diesen Sommer gemerkt,
dass ich endlich
auch meine andere Seite,
meine schwarze Seite annehmen
und darüber sprechen muss.
Kannst du das verstehen?
Ja, ich verstehe das.
Als du geboren wurdest,
war ich nicht an deiner Seite.
Ich war weit weg.
Oui.
Ich weiss,
du hast darunter gelitten.
Ich war nicht da für dich,
meine Anwesenheit hat dir gefehlt.
Über Rassismus
will Angélique Beldners Vater
an diesem Tag mit ihr nicht sprechen.
Für Dinge, die ihn belasten würden,
gehe er in die Kirche.
# Réjouis-toi, Marie,
toute aimée de Dieu.
# Chez vous il revient.
# Ave, Ave, Ave Maria.
Voilà. Merci.
Am nächsten Tag
ist die Schwester zu Hause.
Mit ihr spricht Angélique Beldner
das Thema Rassismus an.
Hast du Rassismus erlebt?
Natürlich.
Und du hast ihn durch mich erlebt,
damals in der Sekundarschule.
(Albert) Ja, in der Sekundarschule
hast du gelitten.
Ich kann mich nicht mehr
an genaue Worte erinnern.
Aber es war, weil ich schwarz bin.
C'était parce que j'étais noire.
Was hast du gedacht?
Wie war das für dich?
Es war hart.
- Das tut weh.
Es tut weh.
Man fühlt sich allein und findet
keine Worte, um sich zu verteidigen.
Dieses Thema anzusprechen ...
Er geht.
Wir werden ihn fragen,
warum er ausgerechnet jetzt geht.
Hast du mit ihm darüber gesprochen?
Nein, wir haben
noch nie darüber gesprochen.
Hat er Angst
oder will er es nicht glauben?
Doch, er glaubt es.
Er hat ja damals
in der Schule interveniert.
Aber ich glaube,
es ist auch für ihn schwierig.
Es ist einfacher, alles zur Seite
zu schieben und so zu tun,
als ginge alles gut,
als würde Rassismus
nicht existieren.
Wenn man nicht darüber spricht,
ist es, als wäre es nicht passiert.
Ce n'est pas si simple.
- Oui.
Aber warum
hast du nicht darüber gesprochen?
Einmal habe ich es erzählt
und dann ...
Ich weiss nicht,
hat man mir die Möglichkeit gegeben,
wirklich darüber zu reden?
Danke.
Es war vielleicht auch der Wunsch,
mich integrieren zu wollen ...
... und diesen Gefühlen
gar kein Gewicht zu geben.
Dann geht es vorbei.
Warum bist du rausgegangen, Albert?
Ich ging etwas holen,
damit ich es nicht vergesse.
Für deine Heimreise.
Und wie ist es heute,
ist es anders?
Mit dem Rassismus?
- Ja.
Ist es besser oder ...
Es ist immer noch da.
Mehr oder weniger.
Ob mehr oder weniger, es ist da.
Ich war z.B. kürzlich
mit einer Reinigungskraft
auf der Pflegestation.
Ich bin schwarz, sie ist weiss.
Die Angehörigen,
die sich informieren wollten,
haben sich aber nicht an mich,
sondern an die weisse Frau gewandt.
Ich verstehe.
Im Kopf der Menschen
sitzt diese Hierarchie einfach fest:
Der schwarze Mensch
bleibt minderwertig.
Oui.
Damals ...
- Ja.
Als ich mit deiner Mutter
zusammen war,
gab es nicht viele Weisse,
die mit einem Schwarzen
ausgegangen wären.
Deine Mutter hat das gemacht.
Die Tatsache,
dass sie das gemacht hat,
machte sie zu einer Kämpferin
gegen den Rassismus.
Diese Trennung von Schwarzen
und Weissen, das wollte sie nicht.
Ja, ja, ja. Das ist gut.
- Ja, das ist gut.
Das ist gut, aber man muss auch
über den Rassismus sprechen.
Ja.
Du sprichst aber nur über ...
... über die guten Sachen.
Die positiven Sachen? Ja.
Aber es gibt auch
die negativen Sachen.
Ja, die gibt es immer.
Wir müssen darüber sprechen,
das ist wichtig.
Ja, damit es aufhört,
damit es weniger wird.
Ja, da bin ich voll und ganz
mit dir einverstanden.
100 % einverstanden.
* Helle, kristallene Klänge *
(Niemals hätte ich gedacht,
dass diese Reise so intensiv wird.)
Albert, au revoir.
- Au revoir, ma fille.
Merci.
- Merci beaucoup.
À bientôt.
(Für mich ist es erschreckend,
zu sehen,
dass meine schwarze Familie
dieselbe Strategie wählte wie ich.)
(Und wie eigentlich
auch meine weisse Familie.)
(Dieser Sommer zeigte mir:
Über Rassismus zu sprechen,
ist schwierig ...
... aber schweigen ist für mich
definitiv keine Option mehr.)
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Philipp Schlatter - 2020